so increasingly humanity finds itself
drowning in information we heart choking
in a deluge of data we are increasingly
suffering from band width anxiety tween
our Twitter feeds and Instagram feeds
and Facebook feeds most people talk
about the fact that now we live in the
attention economy attention is the new
limited resource attention is the new
oil if you don't have a DD today you're
not paying attention this is the
question on everybody's minds how do we
curate what we pay attention to how do
we push aside the noise and focus on
what's important Stewart Brand used to
say science is the only news the rest is
the same he says and she says that you
see in the media and so if I were to be
talking to entrepreneurs if I was
talking to the heads of companies I
would tell them pay attention to
Exponential's pay attention to
disruptive technologies pay attention to
the progress in artificial intelligence
biotechnology nanotechnology right the
big three GNR genetics nanotechnology
and robotics these are the forces that
are appending the world these are the
new trillion-dollar industries that are
going to emerge out of no place think
exponentially pay attention to
disruptive technology